[موسيقى]
يقع هذا القصر الباروكي في الريف ،
وقد تم إرجاعه مؤخرًا إلى
مجده السابق المعروف باسم
الإمبراطورة إليزابيث من النمسا ،
ملكة المجر ، وهو قصر تم
بناؤه حقًا لعائلة ملكية ولكنه
مفتوح اليوم للزوار من كل مكان  أصبحت هذه
القصة الكبيرة ممكنة بفضل
بودابست توابل أوروبا التي تعتبر
إجابة المجر لقصر
فرساي ، هذه التحفة المعمارية الباروكية
تحتوي على كل ما تريده
في قصر
تم الانتهاء منه في قصر الإله الملكي في عام 1748 وتم تقديمه
كعرس.  هدية للملكة الجديدة
وملك المجر ، القصر له شكل W
ومحاطة بحديقة ضخمة
تشكل القاعة الاحتفالية وسط
القصور مخططات متناظرة في الطرف البعيد
من القلعة وهي كنيسة تم تجديدها في عام
واستضافت مسرح باروكي  منتجات
للأرستقراطية المجرية ،
لا تزال العديد من آليات تغيير المشهد
تعمل حتى اليوم
في عام 1867 ،
اشترى البرلمان المجري القصر و  عرضت
القلعة كهدية تتويج لفرانز
جوزيف ملك المجر وإمبراطور
النمسا إمبراطورة النمسا إليزابيث
ملكة المجر المعروفة أكثر بالعامية
حيث كان السيسي مولعًا بشكل خاص
بقصر كادالا واستحم على
الجدران بلونها المفضل البنفسجي بليموث السيسي.
دورًا حيويًا في موازنة القوة
بين النمسا
والمجر ، لقد أحببت المجر وشعبها
وكرست نفسها لتعلم
اللغة المجرية على الرغم من أن
الغرف المتصلة لم تقدم الكثير من حيث
الخصوصية ، إلا أنها كانت تحسنًا ملحوظًا
عن البلاط الملكي الفييني المزدحم
الذي يتميز به القصر  جدران وسقوف
مزينة على الطراز الباروكي الكلاسيكي
، تتميز حديقة القصر بشوارع تصطف على جانبيها الأشجار
ومجموعة متنوعة من
الزهور الجميلة والحياة النباتية
داخل وخارج قصر الله
المناسب حقًا للملكة
[موسيقى]